well here's a question that I think as
parents we probably all know the answer
to are your kids eating enough fruits
and vegetables well if they're a CCSD
student they may be learning how to grow
their own that is pretty cool green our
planet is helping schools across the
district create School Gardens Candace
Charles joining us live from abston
elementary with an impact that it's
making there hi Candace
good morning YouTube good morning folks
yes knowing how to grow on your own
fruits and vegetables can only give you
a sense of Pride but really remind you
of the nutritional value of eating
healthy and green our planet is now in
200 schools throughout Nevada 600
throughout the country they want to make
sure that your child has access to this
as well I have the CEO here with me here
Brian thank you so much for joining us
today now I heard that you guys are also
allowing students to sell some of the
fruits and vegetables absence actually
has the second largest last year that's
right so Epson attended the giant
student farmers market and they made a
lot of money from the fruits and veggies
from their Gardens and some awesome
crafts that they did and I just want to
encourage everybody at home April 21st
put it on your calendar
there will be over 700 students from
Clark County schools selling fruits and
veggies from their Gardens so they need
customers they do get your bags get your
bags out guys and you guys are trying to
make sure that this stays in schools
throughout the nation right how are you
guys doing yeah so one of the
things we're doing this year is that
we're looking for support for our school
garden bill that's passing through the
legislative session right now it's
sponsored by Senator Julie pazina and
we're hoping that people will encourage
their assembly people and Senators to
vote for this bill because voting for
that bill means your kids can continue
having Gardens of their schools amazing
well thank you so much for all the work
you're doing in the community we hope
that everything goes well with the bill
you guys this is so beautiful and
amazing to see and coming up we're going
to be actually speaking to a student and
staff about the amazing Garden here of
course if you want to find out more
about green our planet you can go to our
website newsnow.com for now live from
last snow winter school I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now she woke up a student
on spring break to come in early
um
[Applause]
bro
I decided they are
they armaged it's a good program always
a good sign all right thanks Candace